en seine-et-marne visite à guy drut
chine les ihm perclus kingdom ne sont
pas très fréquente mais c'est un homme
qui aime les animaux
d'ailleurs ce chien de bronze en
témoigne et il a donc eu la gentillesse
de recevoir l'équipe de 30 millions
d'amis avec notre hôte nous parlerons
naturellement de son élevage de pur-sang
l'un des plus célèbres du monde
mais d'abord de son amour quotidien les
ché je crois que je connais voter quelle
l'un des deux je ne sais pas il me
semble avoir rencontré un jour à orly
vous preniez l'avion pour new york vous
aviez ttt qu'elle plein des brad
seulement vraiment fait je n'en avait
qu'un ou une plus exactement c'est cette
vieille fini si il ya 15 ans nous vivons
ensemble depuis un peu plus de 14 en 8es
jour est en voyage quand vous avez pu le
constater vous même
elle est maintenant fatiguée elle voit
mal elle entend mal a presque plus dans
mais elle aime la vie elle est toujours
aussi intelligentes sont nés ne m'a pas
preuve de ses capacités et par
conséquent nous continuons quel
sentiment que vous pour vos chiens c'est
de la fiction c'est sa conjointe
c'est de la tendresse c'est de la
tendresse il y à une telle communion une
telle compréhension quand on veut bien
connaître les bêtes quand on regardait
les examiner les observer et découvrir
les mille petits signes qu'il donne et
que souvent on ne remarque pas et qui
indique des états d'âme des désirs des
craintes des manies et on arrive à avoir
une telle compréhension contre eux
savent que vous les comprenez que vous
comprennent et que c' est un monde et
avec une telle pureté des sentiments une
telle gentillesse une telle naïveté on
ne peut pas ne pas y
vous avez aujourd'hui des animaux oui
oui oui tout droit toute ma vie a
continuellement mais toute ma vie j'ai
des photos quand j'étais tout à fait
enfant tout à fait petit avec un fox
terrier qui était probablement gardé par
la nurse quand j'avais deux trois ans
écoutez on vous imaginerez plus tôt avec
un labrador ou avec un saint bernard où
avec un berger allemand
j'ai toujours eu des chiens qui venait
par hasard j'ai jamais été dans un
magasin choisi en un modèle utilisé mais
cela mon dieu on avait donné un ami un
chien ne voulait pas là je lui ai pris
ce sont une série coïncide ans et ella
teckel oui vieille dame était avait été
donné par des amis espagnols une tente
de ma femme vous élever des chevaux
oui vous élever des chevaux de course en
fait qu'on vire votre écurie a la
réputation d'être avant d'aller à juste
titre la plus populaire auprès du public
mais vos jointe élevée qu'elle sentait
elles sont considérables vous savez j'ai
souvent dit qu'à défaut de course en
course sont un peu le prolongement de
soi même on s'identifie avec le cheval
le jockey cet équipage si vous voulez
qu'il défend vos couleurs
mais quand vous l'avez élevé quand vous
l'avez connu enfant quand vous l'avais
imaginé je ne l'a même pas conçu ce qui
aurait une autre signification mais
quand vous avez imaginé le croisement
que vous avez pensé que telle jument
irait bien avec tel étalon pour toute
une série de raisons que vous avez vu
naître cet enfant que vous l'avez vu se
développer conformément aux en
contradiction avec ce que vous espériez
ou ce que vous pensiez vous le
connaissez vous avez été dans les
herbages vous l'avez caresser vous
l'avez vu à tous les âges ccc c'est
vraiment quelque chose de votre famille
c'est une partie d'août
combien avez vous de chevaux par exemple
la montre à votre âge et nous sommes à
peu près 2 12m un petit peu plus entre
24 et 30 jumeaux et c'est avec ça que je
fais mon album
l'élevage rothschild a la réputation
d'être fort de donner des chevaux
puissant qui tiennent la distance qui
ont beaucoup de trains le tube plus vrai
du temps de mon père qui avait un goût
particulier pour le font par opposition
à la vitesse mais maintenant je crois
que je suis dans la moyenne
vous tenez essentiellement à ne jamais
décevoir le public et vous voulez que
vos cheveux terminer dans les trois
premiers ce média prix soir comme l'on
dit sur les champs de courses pays
vous savez c'est humiliant de participer
à une course nous relever un défi de
dire quand on s'engage à couvrir est un
conte look on espère qu'on pense gagner
c'est pas une loterie c'est tout même
compétition une compétition qui a été
pesée qui a été réfléchie été mesurés
alors bien sûr la nature est ainsi faite
on ne peut pas ne pas être mis en place
et déjà un assez grand nombre de fois
mais le même animal non placé je ne sais
pas combien de fois de suite
de quel droit courtiers
pour la musique qui pour amuser quoi
c'est ridicule ise c'est pénible et le
public qui vous fait confiance qui sait
vous courrez droit vous courrez pour
gagner il faut beaucoup réelles
compétences c'est-à-dire l'aide des
chances réelles d'être dans les premiers
et déçu et on est déçus soi même oui ici
le héros de l'année dernière crystal
palace
le gagnant du jeu club l'année dernière
le cheval qui n'a pu malheureusement
être que troisième de l'arc de triomphe
derrière de fou étrangers enfin c'est
lui qui a sauvé l'honneur de la france
l'année dernière
c'est mon premier gagnant du jour qui
club après tant d'années d'efforts et de
mon père et de moi même
alors vous pensez si je laime en plus
c'est un élève de la maison sa famille
remonta vieille lignée de meautry alors
en plus que j'aime dans cette chose
c'est que ça cheval intelligent car il
n'aime pas les coups de bâton avant ils
preuve d'intelligence weezer tél
deuxièmement il reconnaît les gens
troisièmement il aime le sucre
quatrièmement il a ses petites est
intelligent presque une tête de fox
terrier avec souvent eu l'oreille d'un
côté un petit air malicieux et les
narquois ne veut pas rentrer c'est un
choix qu'on ne peut pas ne pas aimer
figurez-vous il a eu un petit accroc
quand il est arrivé ici en a dû
l'emmener chez le vétérinaire du 20 km
d'ici une petite opération
tout ça se passe très bien il est là bas
et monsieur brillant avec le personnel
d'ici va voir le cheval
le lendemain le ch leur a fait la fête
c'est pas tellement fréquent chez les
chevaux de reconnaître les humains et de
manifester comme ça dans leurs
connaissances dites moi mais ce bel
alezan je le reconnais cédric ce but he
is écurie qui a gagné l'arc de triomphe
en 1963 ça c'est un formidable souvenir
ah oui et pour moi non seulement c'est
un formidable souvenir mais je
n'oublierai jamais le trémolo dans votre
envoi à la télévision
quand vous dites c'est lui c'est lui
c'est trop beau avec une émotion qui
traduisait dans votre voix celle que je
ressens alors maintenant je vais vous
présenter un troisième est annoncée
lightning qui était un cheval très
brillant l'année dernière et dont on
attendait encore beaucoup plus et sa
carrière a été brutalement interrompue
parce qu'on appelle de tic âge c'est à
dire une maladie mauvaises habitudes
atik des chevaux qui en font avaler de
l'air et ce qui donc se gonfler en
avaient réussi à l'empêcher pendant un
temps et puis ensuite il a fait un
voyage en angleterre comme y lisait les
journaux il a eu peur des accidents en
avion et énervé terrifié il a avalé de
l'élan des conditions nouvelles salles a
gonflé il était paralysée comme si on
lui avait rempli une ventre avant une
épreuve et depuis il n'a plus couru et
il n'y avait rien à faire c'est un
cheval impressionnable ceci explique
cela est votre plus belle histoire
d'animaux voyez vous vous faites on chez
rosy trône cette émission sur le mot des
hommes pour les animaux moi j'ai pour
vous une histoire inverse
le maire ici de la commune de tous que
nous sommes et sa femme c'est à
l'industriel parisien maintenant ils ont
habité pendant longtemps en afrique
ils ont élevé notamment un de leurs
enfants un tout petit enfant avec une
guenon qui était extraordinairement
familière qui avait elle même un petit
qu'elle élevait en même temps et un beau
jour à l'horreur des parents la guenon
s'est emparé de son petit et de l'enfant
est monté en haut d'un arbre de 15 m
elle est restée là haut malgré tout les
supplications des parents malgré les
offres de nourriture malgré les menaces
et on pouvait pas tuer la guenon parce
que l'enfant serait tombé en aurait tué
l'enfant
ça a été le désespoir en sait pas quoi
faire
et puis est arrivé un groupe de panthère
elles ont reniflé elles sont parties la
guenon avait compris et savait d'avancé
que les panthères bonne elle est
immédiatement descendus a rendu l'enfant
elle a sauvé l'enfant ça c'est beau
il y a une cinquantaine d'années quand
j'allais à la maternelle n'est turfiste
quand je sais je ne sais pas le bienvenu
bien au pay j'entendais toujours dire
pour payer ton perles jour chill
d'autres mains vides et que vit mon père
avait la réputation de gagner des
courses de 15 avril aux environs du 15
avril au 15 juillet le 15 octobre pour
permettre aux turfiste confiant de payer
leur j'imagine qu'ils ne s'en est jamais
but will généreuse vous dites
chaleureuse ce qui laisse supposer que
vos rapports avec vos chaussons des
rapports presque semblables à ceux que
vous avez avec certains êtres humains
c'est absolument un brin et
naturellement on n'a pas avec les
chevaux les mêmes relations qu'on a
quelqu'un ils ne comprennent pas ils
n'ont pas ils n'ont pas cette relation
avec leurs muses ont une relation rare
est incertaine
alors la dernière question sera la
suivante
préférez vous les chevaux ou l'échec on
peut pas répondre d'abord ce n'est pas
le même emploi reçoit la même relation
je dirais que personnellement n'importe
quel animal qui semble avoir envie d'une
amitié d'un regard de réconfort un lion
qui voudrait être amis un rhinocéros me
touche et cet esprit sensibilité
peut-être ainsi le sensiblerie je ne
sais pas je faisais dix à vis des
animaux qui ont envie ou besoin de
l'homme je les prie pour tous les
animaux
bien sûr la relation avec les chiens
elle vaut la relation avec les hommes et
les quelques fois meilleur nous entrons
en prenant ce débat
non
et
à
m